foreign
welcome back to our next episode of the
series called language shapes perception
and today's topic is going to be about
the Peter Principle some of you might
know what this is but some of you might
not have a clue with the Peter Principle
is and trust me if you already have a
job and if you're working for a company
or similar stuff you have to know what
the Peter Principle is
today I'd like to talk about the Peter
Principle and this is an observation
that in a hierarchy everybody or every
employee tends to rise to their level of
incompetence in other words people are
promoted until they reach a level where
they can no longer do their job well I
will definitely explain a little bit
further
to illustrate this let's say that Bob is
a great employee in a company or in a
corporate or in a school and he's very
good at his job and he is always
reliable his boss recognizes his hard
work and decides to promote him to a
higher position however Bob is not as
good at his new job and he can't keep up
with a new and older workload that he
has to deal with and he's now stuck in a
position that he's not suited for
therefore he's not able to do his job
effectively
the bitter principle is a common problem
in many organizations companies often
promote their best employees to higher
positions without considering if they
are actually qualified for the job the
Peter Principle has been used to explain
a variety of problems in organizations
such as why some managers are
ineffective and why some companies
suffer from higher turnover
there's a lot of examples we can we can
mention here but I'll go back to that or
I'll come back to that a little later it
has also been used to explain why
certain organizations fail to innovate
or take risks in certain times the
bitter principle has been cited in
numerous examples from real companies
for example in 2010 the CEO of helot and
Packard Mark Hurd resigned after it was
revealed that he had falsified expense
reports in order to hide a personal
relationship with a contractor this
example is often cited as an example of
the Peter Principle in action as heard
had been promoted to the position of the
CEO based on his success in a lower
level role and was not able to
effectively handle the higher level of
responsibilities that the position
consisted of another example of the
Peter Principle in action is the case of
the former Yahoo CEO Scott Thompson
Thompson was hired as a Yahoo CEO in
2012 all but it was forced to resign
shortly afterward when he was revealed
that he had lied on his resume about
having a computer science degree
because he he didn't this example
demonstrates how Thompson was promoted
to a higher level role despite not
having the qualifications to effectively
handle the responsibilities of the
position
the Peter Principle is an important
Concept in management Theory and can
also help organizations understand why
certain managers may be ineffective and
why certain companies may suffer from
higher turnovers and why certain
organizations may fail to innovate or
take risks by understanding the Peter
Principle organizations companies
schools or can better understand how to
avoid promoting employees beyond their
level of competence and ensure that
their managers are well equipped to
handle the responsibilities of their
positions to avoid this problem
companies should make sure that they are
promoting employees who are qualified
for the job it's also important to
assess the skills and abilities for the
employee before making a promotion
decision
additionally it's important to provide
employees with the necessary training
and resources to help them succeed in
their new roles however the Peter
Principle can be avoided
and we're going to talk about that in
the next few minutes
you're going to ask how and why is it
important to be avoided or how can we
fix this if we let's say for example if
we come across of a certain example in a
company in the company that we're
working how do we help the manager or
how do we help the board of directors to
avoid or to prevent such cases
organizations should be ensure that
employees are promoted based on their
ability to perform in the next position
rather than their success in their
current role additionally employees
should be given the necessary training
and development to ensure they are
prepared for the next level and not just
use the old experience to do a new kind
of job or to take the new
responsibilities in conclusion we can
say that the Peter Principle is an
important concept to understand it can
lead to inefficiency and stagnation in
an organization but it can be avoided
with proper planning and development
this is a rather modest take on the
Peter Principle
if you really like this episode we can
talk about this more in another episode
which is going to be an extended episode
from from this one
and uh by now I would like to thank you
all for listening to our podcast I hope
you enjoyed our quick dive into this
modest elaboration if you really like
this episode and you're Keen to listen
to similar stuff join us in our next
session next week when we'll be
recording our next episode tackling a
different topic
I'm pretty sure it's going to be an
interesting topic as always you can head
over to our YouTube channel to subscribe
or to sign up to our email list as well
as check out all the links and resources
in the show notes and that's all for now
I guess I'll see you next time thank you
[Music]